- But since your show is
called "Never Have I Ever",
I think that we need to play
a quick round of "Never Ever"-
You've never played "Never Have I Ever".
- I've never done this in an interview.
- Yeah, so we're gonna-
- No. This is so...
for brand new first
time ever in your life,
we're gonna play "Never Have I Ever".
♪ Never have I ever ♪
(audience clapping)
All right. So grab your paddle.
Here we go.
I'm gonna hit this
button that's super close
in proximity to me.
And we both have to
honestly say if we have
or we have never done whatever comes up.
Are you ready?
- Okay.
As I'll ever be.
- All right. Here we go.
- Boom.
- [Maitreyi] Oh. This
is wow. This is like...
Gone skinny-dipping.
'Cause I can't swim.
So why would I want to be naked and drown?
(Kelly laughs)
I can't swim!
I know like I need to work on that.
I need to work on that. I know.
I'm well aware.
This is like a survival thing.
But it's just like a lot of body movement.
- You said, "Why would I ever
want to be naked and drown."
(Kelly laughs)
- I don't wanna be naked and drown.
Like, I'm already gonna drown.
Why would I wanna be naked while doing it?
- Oh, well, girl...
I grew up in the country.
(both laughing)
So I definitely have.
- Best response.
- I'm just saying.
I will tell you, I was terrified though
'cause I was also a nerd
and I loved like all the
history channel things
or Nat Geo or all that kind
of stuff when I was a kid.
And I learned about this thing.
Now, granted I think it was in the Amazon.
But this little thing that can crawl
into like your lady bits
and it can do some damage.
And so I was kind of
afraid to be naked in water
even though I wasn't in the Amazon.
I was like, "It's gonna get me!"
So I kinda swam like a mermaid.
I was like, nothing's getting in there.
- Nice. Protected.
(both laughing)
- I was protecting my goods.
That's what I was doing.
All right, here we go.
- [Maitreyi] Spin the wheel.
- Okay.
- Oh, yeah.
- Passed gas and- (laughs)
- If you're saying you haven't,
that's such a lie.
- You're a liar.
- Why do you think I own a dog?
Like, that's really-
- That's my dog.
I've totally blamed my dog.
- It's Melody. Melody,
why'd you fart, bro?
- You know, granted that
was when I was younger.
Like now, I'll just be like, "My bad."
Like, I'll just-
- That's called accountability.
That's why we love you.
- That's accountability and age.
I think if we've aged,
you just don't care.
Yeah.
- That's fair.
- It just, it leaves.
But I have blamed my dog before.
Okay. Here's another one.
Here we go.
- [Maitreyi] Yes.
- Never have I ever sang
to my stuffed animals?
- Yeah.
I have.
- You have?
- Have you not?
- You know what?
- Was that not a universal experience?
(Kelly laughs)
No?
- Specifically, stuffed animals?
No.
- Really?
- But to like dolls...
Like, I don't know if I did stuffed-
Yo, Care Bears. Yes, I did.
- I love Care Bears.
- I love Care- I love Sunshine.
- I would line up my stuffed
animals like along my bed.
Probably wasn't the best
'cause it didn't leave me
enough room to sleep, but it's okay.
You know, I gotta be kind
to the stuffed animals.
- My daughter does that. Okay.
- I lined them up and
then being like my, what,
like, eight year old, nine year old self
who obviously knows about heartbreak,
I would sing them Adele.
(Kelly laughs)
- The most disappointing and
defeating part of the story
is that you were saying,
"When I was a child listening to Adele."
(Kelly laughs)
Because, well...
- I understand.
- I was not.
All right. Here we go.
Boom.
Never have I ever
broken a bone.
Ooh, I have never.
- I have never, either.
- I have bent a bone. Two.
- What did you do?
- I have fallen off a
horse and bent my tailbone
perpendicular to my spine
which, I guess, is a forever thing.
Super fun.
And also, I bent my pinky. See?
I was in a bike accident.
And I...
Yeah, it's bent.
- Battle scars.
- Never broken.
- Never broken a thing.
- That's a song.
"Bent But Never Broken".
- Mm. Yeah.
- Let's write it.
Mm.
- I like that.
- You said, "Mm."
- Have some sauce on it.
I don't know. I like it.
I never broke anything.
I fall down all the time.
But as a child, I'd, you know,
slip through like table
legs and like small gaps.
Totally dislocated some stuff.
- Oh.
- But I think
I was doing a favor to my mom.
You know, keeping her on her toes.
- Yeah.
- Keeping things interesting.
Like, how boring would it be
if I didn't do that stuff?
- You're a half glass full kind of girl.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
I am so glad you're
sticking around. I love you.
"Never Have I Ever" is now on Netflix
and season two is coming this July
so everybody look for it and check it out.